y'all see that cactus back there it's my
cactus his name is Steve saw this cute
little old man look at him and say hey
that's a really cute cactus on my bike
so you know what I did
snatch that [ __ ] first and I said nice
try [ __ ] hey what is going on
YouTube now there is something that has
been on my mind that I do want to
address and I understand that this is a
comedy page but at the same time it's my
[ __ ] patient I could say whatever I
want now the thing that has been on my
mind is this thing I call perception of
reality now a lot of the times I read
these type of comments and they kind of
get on my nerves not because people that
we know are saying something dumb is
because it's a reflection of what people
think reality is and then now before I
get chewed out let me just explain to
you what this is [ __ ] too many people
out there think that social media is
reality I'm gonna tell you this right
now the social media the things that you
see on Instagram and a lot of the stuff
that you see people post is not [ __ ]
reality you know those people that you
follow or you see their vlogs or
something and every morning they wake up
and they're like I'm walking on sunshine
it's mainly for one thing it's for
entertainment and it's for views it's
not a reflection of their reality have
you noticed there's been this huge trend
on vloggers coming out saying some [ __ ]
like for many years I've suffered with
depression and then a lot of you are
kind of like oh my god how can they ever
be that well that's because you believe
in everything that you see or hear now
the reason why I want people to be
mindful of this [ __ ] is basically for
one thing what I want you guys to
realize is that you have a life of your
own and to stop comparing it to somebody
else's - especially to the people that
you don't [ __ ] know I'm not telling
that everybody out there that you see
that's happy on their Instagram is not
really happy and they're sad and there's
but what I'm saying is is that you
shouldn't compare your life to things
that are fictional as much as these
[ __ ] youtubers the social media [ __ ]
want to tell you hey man you know
everything about my life
you don't you absolutely [ __ ] don't
and if you do know everything about
their life holy [ __ ] and some of you
might say this we're not looking at it
like it's reality or comparing our lives
we just want to see the cool things that
other people do that's how it originally
starts but I keep winning comments and I
keep getting these emails about
people are telling me yo I'm not
satisfied with my life how can I live my
life like yours [ __ ] let me tell you
about my [ __ ] life if you see me do a
lot of cool things like traveling and
experience things the other 90% that you
don't see is the fact that I'm running
multiple businesses on the side and the
fact that I'm working on features and
the fact that I'm sitting in my [ __ ]
room writing all day but see you don't
know that
it's not the stuff that I post because
number one it's not there for me to post
that's like stuff that I'm doing on my
own grind it's not the stuff that I want
to share on social media your life is
[ __ ] okay and I get it - there's a
reason why you know we follow people
like dan Bilzerian the [ __ ] bajillion
billionaire with [ __ ] titties and
asses in his face all day but guess what
you're not dan Bilzerian
I'm not dan Bilzerian we don't have a
billion [ __ ] dollars [ __ ] can
I tell you something if I had a billion
dollars my life would be
fan-fucking-tastic - I'm not sure if I
would have that many titties or asses in
my [ __ ] face but I'm pretty damn sure
I'd be doing some crazy [ __ ] I would
somehow find a shark somehow find a
horse attach a unicorn horn to its head
and had those two kiss each other
without killing each other it's weird
I know it's I have a billion dollars
what the [ __ ] do you care let's social
media be social media okay let that
world exist on its own if you guys want
to escape from your reality to kind of
like imagine and see what it would like
to be somebody else that's cool but
don't let that reflect on your own life
if you are following somebody on
Instagram that you look up to you're
supposed to use them as an example to
further your own life and better your
life now for you to sit there and wallow
about why your life sucks and I gotta
say - one of the bigger reasons why a
lot of people think this way - is
because of a lot of these social media
[ __ ] that perpetuate this idea - like I
am the reason why you're happy I am the
reason why you get to wake up in the
morning I am the reason why you laugh
like you choose to live [ __ ] you no
you're not I've heard some of the most
cockiest [ __ ] in the way like youtubers
deal with social media hate they're like
you know what I'm doing what I'm doing
I'm staying on my grind
I'm the one with money these kids aren't
killing themselves because on the one
that makes them happy [ __ ] you you
self-centered [ __ ] [ __ ] the reason
why people don't kill themselves and the
reason why they choose to live is be
because they chosen not because of you
you're not that [ __ ] special bro
don't take away somebody's strength and
choice to live as if it was your doing
[ __ ] if it wasn't you it would
have been somebody else that made them
laugh they are strong not because of you
a lot of people out there they chase
Fame and they chase this pseudo sense of
happiness man you will see some of the
people out there who have the most money
and the most recognition still chase
that fame like a bunch of dirty [ __ ]
about how weird this concept is and you
could disagree with me or whatever
because you think I'm [ __ ] old cuz
I'm in my late 20s listen some of you
[ __ ] out there take down photos because
it doesn't have enough likes what you
take down a photo because you are not
getting affirmation from random people
because it's not making you feel good
and then you had the audacity to say
that the only person that you create for
is yourself [ __ ] you create because
the reason why you wake up is to receive
affirmation from people the only reason
why you're happy is if other people tell
you that you're good that you're doing
something right and these same people
are the ones that are giving you advice
on how to live your life [ __ ] them [ __ ]
me come for the entertainment comforta
laughs not all of us are going to be
your heroes there are people out there
that are right next to you that are
human beings that you could connect with
that can be your heroes that are a
better [ __ ] example maybe your mom
maybe your dad maybe your uncle maybe
like some people in your community that
you can look up to that are doing
amazing things in their lives or in our
lives I'm making this video to tell you
all that you shortchange yourselves way
too much by comparing yourselves to
people who really aren't real you know
you see the vlogs where [ __ ]
wake up in the morning and like good
learning Izzy Bernie who the [ __ ] wakes
up if you wake up to me live here with
my breath snaking your like heating you
want some [ __ ] AIDS that will
actually you know what if you Rob
exercise humans don't wake up like that
and if you do you probably looked around
and you realize that you're in a [ __ ]
insane asylum I must say it once again
just to put it in your head the people
that you follow including me use the
positivity
as inspiration but not as a way to put
yourself down not everything that you
see on the internet is real not
everything shows you the whole picture
understand that you are important that
your life is dictated by the actions
that you make if you want your Instagram
to look all great and pretty then go
ahead
live the life that allows for that to
happen because think about it for a
second if you are so busy worrying about
what other people think about the stuff
that you're posting about what other
people think about your life if they
thumbs up your [ __ ] and you're so
focused on creating a fictional life
when do you have the time to actually
live one yourself that's all I got a
poop oh [ __ ]
Oh hope you guys liked that video and if
you guys did not like that conversation
you thought it was a little too real for
a pimple but Vicky's doing on my channel
but in all seriousness if you guys want
to see more stuff that you guys want me
to talk about feel free to leave it in
the comments below because I can just
give you my thoughts on them and if you
think it's hilarious then adios kudos to
you I just spoke Spanish it doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense oh and don't be afraid
to give this things a thumbs up and
don't be afraid to come back to give it
more views because hahaha thinking about
something